the log of a to the base B is equal to X
how do we write this in the exponential
form we can write it as B raised to X is
equal to a both the equations tell us
the same thing now before we move
forward there are a few fundamental
properties we need to know let's discuss
the first one what will log of 1 to the
base B be equal to how do we find this
answer I encourage you to pause the
video and find the answer to this say it
equals x in the exponential form it's
kind of written as B raised to X is
equal to 1
remember the exponential form is what
most of us are comfortable with this can
help us find the value of x for the
answer to be 1 the power here has to be
0 do you remember that property of
exponents any nonzero number raised to 0
is equal to 1 hence X here is 0 the log
of 1 to any base will always equal 0 log
of 1/2 the base 12 is equal to 0 log of
1/2 the base 250 is also equal to 0 that
was the first fundamental property we
looked at log of 1 to any base will
always equal 0 now let's move on to the
second property what will be the value
of log of B to the base B give it a shot
assume that it equals x so in the
exponential form it can be written as B
raised to X is equal to B what will be
the value of x here come on it's easy B
to the power 1 will equal B X will be
equal to 1 the log of B to the base B
will equal 1 if the argument and the
base are the same then the logarithm
will be 1 for instance the log of 4 to
the base 4 will be equal to 1 that was
the second property the third one is
pretty cool it talks about the log of B
raised to n to the base B assuming the C
equals x try writing this in the
exponential form it is written as B
raised to X is equal to B raised to n
it's pretty clear X has to be equal to n
so the log of B raised to n to the base
B will equal n an example would be log
of 11 cube to the base 11 will equal 3
so these are the three fundamental
properties of logarithms and we don't
really need to remember these as they
can be easily derived along with the
properties there are a few conditions we
need to know about let's see them on the
right side of the board the basic form
of logarithm is written like this where
a is the argument and B is the base now
for this to be valid there are a few
conditions about a and B that we need to
know okay first the argument has to be
greater than zero this value here has to
be greater than zero so log of 0 to the
base B is undefined and the log of a
negative number to the base B is also
incorrect but don't get confused here
the answer of the log can be 0 or
negative for example as we saw here the
log of 1 to the base B will be 0 this
this is correct and what will be log of
1/2 to the base 2 it will equal negative
1 as 2 raised to negative 1 is equal to
1
/ - or 0.5 this is also correct the
answer can be 0 or negative but the
argument has to be greater than 0 what
are the conditions for B the base B has
to be greater than 0 and it cannot be
equal to 1 yes
the base B cannot be equal to 1 so the
log of a to the negative number base is
incorrect why is 1 not allowed us the
base I want you to tax your brain a bit
and come up with an answer why can't the
base be equal to 1 let's say the base
was 1 and we have a logarithmic
expression like log of a to the base 1
is equal to X in the exponential form it
can be written as 1 raise to X is equal
to a what can be the value of x that
gives us a if a is 2 what will X B if a
is 5 what will X be equal to we can't
really come up with an answer because 1
raised to any number will result in a 1
hence this will be undefined so these
were the three simple primary properties
of logs and these were the conditions
with this we can move ahead and solve
interesting examples
you